hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar factors to consider during
adaptation of a manual cell line
development workflow to automation i am
michelle ashton of lappers can all be
your moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
labyrinth and brought to you by Beckman
culture to learn more about our sponsor
please visit www.netsupportdna.com the
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen this presentation is
educational and best offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
on the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits I now present today's
speaker Rob Ballinger of alexion
Pharmaceuticals incorporated for the
complete biography on our speaker please
visit the biography tab at the top of
your screen Rob Ewing that begin your
presentation
hello my name is Rob Ballinger and I'm a
development associate for at alexion
Pharmaceuticals in the upstream
development group this group includes
cell line development
we recently converted our manual cell
line development process to an automated
workflow I'll present some factors to
consider during adaptation of a manual
cell line development workflow to an
automation based on what we've learned
in that experience let me just mention
this disclaimer the views contained in
this presentation do not reflect neither
an endorsement from alexion
Pharmaceuticals Inc nor partnership or
collaboration between alexion
Pharmaceuticals Inc and Beckman Coulter
let's start with a description of the
basic cell line development workflow it
starts with a number of transient
transfection x' for molecule evaluations
this step could be an iterative process
as additional or modified molecules may
be repeatedly evaluated a selected lead
molecule or molecules are transfected
into host cells with the plasmid
containing the gene of interest and a
selection marker to generate a stable
cell line transfected cells are then
placed under selective pressure to
select for clones containing the gene of
interest cells can then be plated to
isolate single cell clones these clones
are then expanded to various vessels of
increasing growth area or volume and
finally evaluated to choose the best
clones for master cell banking and
manufacturing scale production and
although depicted as such this is not an
entirely linear process with clone
numbers expanding and contracting at
various points and potential off suits
of productivity product quality or clone
quality evaluation going forward I will
be focusing on the out growth and
expansion portion of the workflow
that cell line development workflow lies
within the critical path of drug
development further product development
cannot continue prior to a cell line
being developed and a lead clone
selected how can we shorten that time
line
an automated process with increased
throughput can provide the ability to
prosecute more cell line development
projects potentially enabling the
initiation of cell line development
prior to final molecule selection this
allows molecule triage to occur
concurrently with cell line development
so by the time of final molecule is
selected cell lines have already been
developed
one of the challenges we are trying to
address within the scope of increasing
throughput is to increase the number of
clones produced this is a bottleneck in
our workflow we want to increase the
number of clones produced and be able to
handle that increased number however
higher throughput with its associated
increased evaluation equals more
resources required therefore we need to
decrease resources as for decreasing
time we are limited by the speed of cell
growth however we could evaluate clones
sooner to generate a selected subset of
clones sooner and that cone evaluation
could involve for example not just titer
but linking it with cell number to get
specific productivity or other factors
that provide more predictive power of
clone performance at scale what we
really want to do is find better clones
faster
you
one way to address the challenge of
decreasing resources while handling
increased throughput of greater numbers
of clones is automation process steps
like incubation plate imaging and clone
evaluation can be integrated to the
liquid handling steps of scale-up
providing the ability to process more
clones with less resources
the automation system could include a
liquid handler at its core integrated
with various devices these devices could
include ambient storage hotels for
storage of consumables to be accessed
during the process incubators for
culture plates imaging devices for
Monacan ality or growth monitoring and
other analytics devices for clone
assessments all or part of the system
can be enclosed in a laminar flow
enclosure to maintain sterility let's
look at how a manual workflow evolves
into the workflow on an automated liquid
handling platform
this workflow starts with 96-well plates
gala proceeds through various multi-well
plates
perhaps 48 well and 24 well as seen here
clones are then transferred to t25
flasks and ultimately they're banked
the use of liquid handling robotics
allows easy integration of 384 well
plates at the beginning of the workflow
this instantly increases density of
clones fourfold allowing more clones to
be produced in the same area or
retaining the same level of clone
production in a smaller area this can
provide space for more cell line
development projects permitting
development of cell lines for multiple
candidate molecules in the same
footprint has one candidate molecule and
allowing cell line development to begin
sooner but the t25 flask is not easily
adapted to automation but let's first
look at the addition of the 384-well
plate to the workflow
as a new culture condition the optimal
plate construction had to be chosen cell
growth had to be sufficient and the
plate has to fit well and to others
aspects of workflow such as imaging once
the plate is chosen the optimal growth
time and the 384 well plates had to be
determined
now that this 96-well plate fits into
the workflow at a different point now
the second plate in the workflow rather
than the first the culture time in the
96-well plate also has to be determined
in the manual workflow culture started
in the 96-well plate from a single cell
refer to the red line on the chart
starting at zero percent confluence now
in the automated workflow the 96-well
plates will be seated with cultures from
the 384-well plate those 384-well plate
started with a single cell but have
grown for a period of time the 90s
6-well plate in the automated workflow
now start with a higher confluence than
the 96-well plates in the manual
workflow refer to the blue line on the
chart starting at a higher confluence
experiments to determine how this shifts
the curve have to be performed to
determine the proper growth time in the
96-well plate in the automated workflow
as we incorporate new plate types and
translate our workflow to automation we
have the issue of converting the manual
transfer of a semi adherent colony to an
automated liquid handler method manually
transferring a semi adherent colony is a
simple task of pipetting up and down
while moving the pipette tip across the
bottom of the well then tipping the
plate to aspirate the entire volume a
basic liquid handling technique seen
here in the top panel of briefly mixing
in the center of the well only transfers
limited cells solutions include multiple
mixes for small wells
such as those in the 384-well plate this
also has to be tested as excessive
aspiration or dispensed speed could
affect cell health as could excessive
numbers of mixes
for larger wells a moving dispense
depicted in the bottom panel could be
utilized emulating what is performed by
a person this method and other liquid
handling operations were developed with
extensive support from an expert at
Beckman Coulter mixes are performed at
edge locations with dispenses occurring
as tip moves across the well dislodging
cells as it goes so mixing at location 1
then aspirating at location 1 then
dispensing while moving across the well
from location 1 to location 2 and so on
again there is much optimization of this
process how much volume should be mixed
how fast can we mix without losing
viability but still massaging sufficient
cells
what pattern should we use with a moving
dispense to dislodge the most cells can
all of this be accomplished in the
reasonable amount of time as we would
like to maximize throughput and minimize
the time the culture is out of the
incubator another lesson learned during
the process was that we did not need to
tilt the plate as we do in our manual
workflow to aspirate sufficient volume
from the well performing the final
aspiration close to the edge and bottom
of the well was sufficient
back to our workflow now we've added the
384-well plate and adapted the 96-well
step
forty-eight well and 24 well scale up
vessels can remain unchanged except for
adaptation of liquid handling techniques
as just explained
but as I mentioned earlier the t25 flask
is not easily adapted to automation
let's look at four options to replace
tea flasks
single well plates trade name is Omni
tray six well plates using multiple
wells of multi-well plates 24 well
plates are shown here and deep well
plates used either shaken or stationery
let's look at the advantages and
disadvantages of each
one will plate of Greater culture area
than a t25 but can be difficult to
handle on a robotic platform with
potential sloshing of medium during
plate movements six well plates are easy
to handle robotically but possessed less
culture area than a t25 multiple wells
of any plate size increased culture area
but sample tracking could get
complicated deep well plates can be
handled robotically but perform best
shaking so a shaking incubator would
need to be integrated or the step would
have to be taken offline bringing back a
limitation of the tea flask
looking at how many vessels would be
required for a set of say twenty four
clones single well plates are one for
one occupying 24 positions in automation
what was on the deck and in an incubator
six well plates gain is some space
occupying only four spots multiple wells
in this example two of a 24 well plate
gets us down to two spots for 24 clones
a deep well 24 well gets us to one plate
for 24 clones but would have to be taken
offline per our workflow the 612 was the
best compromise of culture area and
space required while giving good culture
growth and viability
but as a new culture vessel 6-well plate
culture conditions needed to be
optimized using cell numbers estimated
to be similar those from cultures coming
from the 24 well plate the previous
culture step cultures of a range of
volumes were initiated cell viability
was measured through an anticipated
culture duration a culture volume was
then selected to move forward in the
chart in all three starting cell
densities culture volume a the lightest
blue line returned the best cell
viability and a culture duration of less
than four days was required to maintain
viability
selection of culture volume should also
be informed by pipetting method for
example a starting volume of nineteen
hundred microliters would require three
pipetting trips per well if your pipette
tip can only hold nine hundred
microliters keeping air gaps both
leading and trailing in mind of 1025
micro litre pipette tip holds less
volume than a thousand 25 microliters
and practice an 1,800 micro litre
starting volume requires one fewer trip
per well and could save many minutes per
scale-up process again we have to
optimize by petting test techniques for
the 6-well plate
optimizing pipetting techniques for the
6-well plate not only means pipetting
methods of culture transfer like we've
already discussed but of filling the
plate with fresh medium it is best to
pre-fill the destination plate with
fresh medium prior to addition of the
culture that is being scaled up this
allows the option of tips to be used
repeatedly to fill multiple wells
without chance of cross-contamination
however repeated tip usage can result in
medium remaining in the tips and with
large aspiration volumes that remaining
medium can lead to drips or it could
reach the filter causing improper
aspiration or dispensing to reduce the
amount of medium left in the tips a slow
dispense rate can be used to allow the
maximum amount of medium to sheet down
the tip during the dispense so little
remains in the tip this results in a
time-consuming plate fill method a
potential solution is the use of wide
bore tips the wider bore and difference
in tip shape allows a faster dispense
with minimal medium remaining in the tip
reducing the possibility of drips and
medium contacting the filter adding a
delay before blowout reduces liquid
retention even further this could allow
reusing tips across multiple wells with
tips being changed less frequently
during the method tip usage is another
factor to consider as sufficient deck
space needs to be allowed for the tips
used and the time taken to change tips
expense method time
now that we have our automated workflow
plan it has to be tested with an actual
representative cell line development
campaign type adding methods can then be
optimized with truly representative
cultures exhibiting representative cell
number positioning and adherence this
also allows the actual culture time
required and each new plate type to be
evaluated at each scale-up step
decisions the scale-up can also be
automated
when it comes time to scale up in a
manual workflow a confluence II
criterion can be subjective with an
automated workflow the confluency
criterion can be specifically defined
but confluency for example is variable
if 50% is chosen in this example the
colony on the left is not chosen but the
colony on the right is scaled up a
higher confluency criterion leads to
missing some clones with slower growth
but perhaps high specific productivity
perhaps the colony on the left but
selected clones should have better
growth selection of clones with lower
confluency equals more clones but they
will contain slower growers workflows
will be defined on best case or typical
scenarios but we continue to evaluate
perhaps scaling up at 20% confluence
causes lagging at the next culture step
due to excessive split ratio but waiting
for 80% confluence results in loss of
viability
besides confluence there are other
assessments of clones assessment of
clones in a manual process may be
performed at a convenient point with
convenience defined by ease and sampling
for example assessing clones at the
96-well step due to the ability to use a
multi pipette for sampling a liquid
handling platform can make sampling at
the 96 wheel step even easier by using a
96-well pipetting head however perhaps
there is reduced predictive power of
measurements at that stage perhaps
sampling at a later stage is in fact
more predictive of the parameter being
assessed recall my earlier statement and
the objective finding better clones
faster liquid handling platform would
not find this as inconvenient as a human
sampler
I've described how a manual cell line
development workflow can change when
automation is implemented now let's look
at how the job itself of cell line
development might change
the first step is of course learning the
operation of the liquid handling
platform from there is the process I've
described up adapting your process to
automation I've mentioned a few lessons
learned in the process such as not
needing to tip a plate during certain
aspiration steps it also caused us to
look more closely at each step
particularly in regards to scale-up
timing as this can be scheduled the
process management software do all this
your daily activities have evolved from
pipetting to programming let's look a
little closer at each of these points
you
the first step is learning to operate
the liquid handling platform
that begins with the biomech software
that controls all the functions of the
liquid handler if that liquid handler is
integrated into other equipment such as
incubators plate hotels plate imagers
plate readers or other hardware another
layer of software Sammy is recommended
for easier method scheduling if multiple
cell line development campaigns will be
run with overlapping timelines they can
be scheduled and tracked with Sammy
process management each of these comes
with its own learning curve and time
required to fully master beckman coulter
has provided extensive training and
support through this learning process
as previously described your workflow
needs to be adapted to the automated
platform during that process there were
lessons learned culture volumes and
durations for optimal growth and each
plate type were determined pipetting
methods were written and optimized for
speed and technique such as air gaps and
tip touching added where necessary plate
placement on deck was modified to
minimize contamination possibilities
plate locations on the liquid handler
deck were selected where the pipetting
head would cross over the least amount
of culture area during handling
you can notice through this process of
manual to automation the job itself of a
cell line developer is changing the
concern of one's job being replaced by a
robot is not necessarily appropriate
your daily activity changes from
pipetting cultures to teaching a robot
how to pipette cultures and supplying
that robot with necessary inputs the
ergonomic concerns of repetitive
pipetting are replaced with the concerns
of working at a computer the concept of
doing each step better remains and if a
robot is performing much of the basic
workflow tasks there can be more time
available for researchers to perform
those experiments they've been wanting
to do if only they had the time while
the robot scales up the clones you
complete themselves in the new medium
you wanted to try
another change in daily activities is in
methods of data management tracking of
clones in a manual workflow might
involve spreadsheets of clone ids and
locations on plates with descriptions of
which clones were scaled up on what day
this process can be automated with the
database tracking the path of each clone
through the workflow data from external
analysis can be uploaded and appended to
each clones history a lesson learned
here is to confirm remaining database
space prior to beginning a campaign the
database requires sufficient free space
to fully record operations and to
operate efficiently depending on your
workflow database size used at each step
in the campaign can vary the database
must be properly configured to contain
the data generated periodic archives are
a good way to maintain available space
besides the lessons learned mentioned
previously there are broader lessons as
well
implementing an automated workflow
requires not only the obvious capital
investment but also a significant time
investment even without workflow changes
translation of the manual workflow to
automation requires significant
programming time with repeated testing
of methods as discussed changing or
adding vessels requires testing and
optimizing with your cell lines and the
automation system optimizing just the
aspiration of a single culture step
could take days of testing
bringing us to the next point test test
test this point was partially addressed
in regards to process adaptation but it
is worth mentioning again initial tests
are run with empty plates to confirm lab
wear movements later tests are run with
medium
here we confirm pipetting techniques
aspirate at the proper speed to allow
rapid aspiration while still allowing
the liquid to fill the tip dispense
speeds are also tested to determine the
speed that allows proper emptying of the
tip and doesn't result in dripping due
to continued cheating of the liquid down
the tip after the dispense is completed
these effects will not be seen with
water cell culture medium has a
sufficiently different viscosity and
surface tension that it will perform
differently
then you may run tests with culture with
a representative cell density later you
may realize that the medium pipettes
differently after a number of days of
incubation than it did in the test place
after testing with single or small
numbers of plates your method may not
behave as you would like after
representative numbers of plates are
included with robotic actions performed
in the interest of efficiency but not in
the interest of your cells running one
or several test campaigns could be
helpful as even after multiple campaigns
have been run you may still be
optimizing finally seeing things that
don't occur until real-world conditions
are met transitioning to the automated
workflow too soon could result in
timeline delays if the automated
workflow fails
your first run of an actual cell line
development campaign requires either
full trust in the system sufficient
backup plates or a simultaneous manual
workflow
all of these require additional
resources trust in the system is
developed with sufficient testing back
up plates require greater equipment use
simultaneous manual workflow requires
Human Resources who therefore may not be
available for the automated workflow
during the implementation and testing
getting all potential users to the same
level of expertise is helpful while one
super user may be the primary operator
if there are multiple people in the
group using the system an adequate level
of ability and comfort is important
so let's look at the result of all this
and how it meets the objectives listed
at the beginning
the first objective was increasing the
number of quality clones produced 384
well plates increased clones per plate
automation can handle more plates these
are two steps towards more clones once
the automation is self-sufficient there
will be time for process improvements
such as testing new coding mediums that
could lead to a gain and clone outgrowth
the second objective was decreasing
resources Automation can allow more
clones to be processed than in the
manual workflow without a proportional
increase in full-time employee time
these gains come again from the ability
to use 3d for well plates which
increases the number of clones per plate
over 96-well plates the ability to
process more plates and the ability to
perform other tasks while the automation
system is performing the scale-up
imaging sampling and other clone
processing tasks
with the ability to handle more clones
and more plates an automated process can
provide the ability to prosecute more
cell line development projects as
introduced earlier potentially allowing
initiation of cell line development
prior to find a molecule selection this
allows molecule triage to occur
concurrently so by the time a final
molecule is selected cell lines have
already been developed
with more clones that are easier to
handle we have moved the start of cell
line development back off the critical
path producing manufacturing ready cell
line sooner
so in conclusion automation is increased
throughput without an increase in
resources after methods are adapted and
optimized increased throughput allows
more clones to be produced or more
candidate molecules to be pursued
potentially allowing cell line
development to begin earlier in CMC
development automated workflows require
adaptation of manual workflows
occasionally with significant time input
automated workflows may be
counterintuitive to manual workflows
such as filling a plate on demand just
as it enters a workflow where a person
would rather pre fill all plates prior
to beginning scale-up
increased throughput increases our
chances of finding better cones since we
can produce and process more clones and
potentially use improved or additional
evaluation techniques to better evaluate
more clones we have increased our
chances of finding a better clone
looking through more hay gives us a
better chance of finding the needle
close I would like to acknowledge those
people here at Alexia and at Beckman
Coulter that made this webinar possible
thank you for your time
thank you rob for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for let's get started
our first question is you mentioned test
test test how long was the process
optimization and how did you maintain
productivity during this time yes we
spent about six months after
installation on method writing
development and testing during his time
selling develop projects were completed
manually we would have actually
preferred a little more time but we
needed to initially a cell line
development project on the automation at
that time so that project became what
amounted to our first real shakedown run
we did have sufficient confidence in the
system at the time so it wasn't a
massive leap of faith and we ran
sufficient number of plates to account
for any method failures we might have
what is the comfort level of your group
members when it comes to using biomech
and Sammy software how was their
learning curve
most of our group is now quite
comfortable with the software with three
power users of column two of the power
users had used other automation systems
in the past so they took through the
software very quickly becoming very
skilled in just a couple of months we
all continue to learn to this day but we
are very comfortable with it now
great thank you what are the top three
factors you considered when selecting
back then as your automation vendor I
would say their previous experience with
integrated systems the customer support
and the capability of the system I'll
adjust each of those Beckman showed that
the biomech and Sammy software can be
integrated with just about anything and
they had integrated equipment like ours
in the past including sterile enclosures
they provided the best support through
the vendor selection process and
continue to do so and the biomech itself
had the liquid handling capabilities
that met or exceeded other options
thank you looks like we have time for
one more question why you need to decide
to automate only a part of your cell
line development workflow earlier stages
in the workflow such as transfection
we're low throughput and easily perform
manually so we didn't need to optimize
those but on automation later stages
such as those after the six well stage
can be automated but it would require
greater time and capital investment than
we were interested at the time we were
and continue to be comfortable with
executing those stages manually
thank you again Rob for your time today
in your important research we would also
like to face labyrinth and our sponsor
Beckman culture for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
do not have time for today and those
that is during the on demand period will
be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration lab routes will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event until
next time goodbye